this video is sponsored by Red Shadow
Legends raid Shadow Legends is what
would happen if you crossed a
Blockbuster movie with a triple A game
and squeezed all of that onto your
mobile it's a turn-based MMO RPG that
lets you game against your friends and
millions of other players online you can
download the game onto your PC or your
mobile phone using the QR code on screen
now or by clicking my link in the
description below the game is
action-packed one minute you're heading
to a dungeon to face off against really
challenging bosses the next you're back
to the campaign and picking fights with
other players in high stakes PVP there's
never a dull moment in this game I also
love that you can drop into a game with
your mates team up with the squad play
against other teams in Clan tournaments
and the kick of the new year there's a
fresh raid update with a bunch of new
features including a new season of the
forge pass where you can earn in-game
goodies including a legendary champion
and more and Ronda Rousey actually has
made the leap into the world of raid
with her very own Champion you can get
Ronda simply by opening raid on seven
days for February 20th and you can use
the code red Rhonda to get loads of
useful in-game items to level her up so
there you have it don't forget download
raid by clicking the link in the
description below and you can get access
to your welcome pack directly from me
but for now enjoy the video
welcome back to True Jordan YouTube
channel today's video is about why I
hate the internet it will make sense
soon don't forget to like And subscribe
so this young lady's gone viral uh
because she recorded herself working out
at the gym with a man in the background
and basically try to make him look like
a predator this is how to not approach
girls at the gym
I hate this I hate this I hate when
they're sweeters makes me so
uncomfortable
okay so when I first watched this video
I thought like this girl has no doubt
been harassed this guy's gonna come up
and really do some bad [__] here like
you're thinking wow this must be bad
this got a lot of views uh no as you'll
see
um she's called him a stupid piece of
[__] for a start he's glanced at her
twice it might have something to do with
the fact that she's pointing a camera
right at him without his consent or that
she's muttering to herself like a
lunatic Barrel feral like [__] feral
what does feral mean because definitions
of a feral man a person who's not
socialized raised by Apes that's not a
very nice thing to say is it shouting
feral feral [__] feral in the middle
of a gym isn't really sociable
whoa okay okay so let's just get this
straight this is horrifying apparently
feral feral [__] feral but but isn't
that bad honestly she is a loving this
moment here and that is why you know
this is disingenuous that alone we're at
15 seconds he has a news flash when you
go to the gym sometimes people are out
of order I get that but generally
speaking men and women when they're
working out in the gym will look up at
each other we'll notice each other I
look at men and women some names and see
what they're doing in the gym because
it's just interesting to watch people
work out or they need helping or they
they form terrible whatever that's just
gym life mirrors everywhere so it's like
you can easily can't catch people
oh this is nothing
it is nothing it's a fishing weight love
so bear in mind she's fast forwarding
her crap work out here which is piss
week and he's still not in the picture
he's not looking he's not there he
doesn't care if he was some weird perv
he would have at least been hovering in
the background and keeping an eye on her
if this is the narrative she wants to
pick he's he's [__] off he doesn't
care
I mean that was a glance this woman is
putting him on the internet as if he's a
predator and he's literally just [__]
doing what anyone does in a gym
for for a second
because she's struggling to load the bar
and this guy you can see by his physique
is built has a lot of gym experience and
knows what he's doing whereas with with
her struggling with the lightest way
it's possible he knows she hasn't got a
[__] clue
no no it's okay I got it thank you
though okay so he's just offering us
some help trying to put away it on the
side I've done that with a million
people I've had loads of people come up
to me and James will you spot me or
other stem can you help me out like it's
just gym etiquette you know what I mean
it's very normal this he was only
working out behind me to go up to me
because I was a squat rack all the way
in the corner of the gym to avoid
weirdos like this
I mean
how do you know what was going on in his
head you're assuming that like he was
literally working out his lower back a
minute ago which you can see that they
don't have many machines like this in a
gym it's right in the corner you know
she's literally making her own ideas up
here
there you go he's just wiping it down
not a big deal end a story with it what
if I just ripped his pee pee out of its
socket so he could never reproduce again
I think we need Jesus or therapy here
because this is not the your thoughts
aren't the normal ones love you're crazy
if a man uploaded a video like this
right let's just be real and said
something like that about a woman
looking at him in the gym world war
three would break out this is insane
Behavior this is why I don't want kids
look why you don't want kids is a far
bigger issue than this guy in a gym you
need to just go home and just reconcile
with your dad
[__] it up natural selection better take
these weirdos out I mean it just
literally tried to help her he's going
to jail for staring at an underage 21
year old make it make sense oh she's so
desperate to be a victim of anything
anything that she's making out like 21
is underage this is nuts here's the
[__] problem right is being a victim
on the internet has become such a cushy
number that people are actively wanting
to be a victim you know you've got real
people out there who've been through
hell and you get so much sympathy and
Weirdos ironically what she's calling
him look at that and go I want that I
want to be a victim victims are special
victims get sympathy empathy they get
all the love and attention and that's
the key word here attention and it's a
great place to be so let me find a way
where I can be a victim too you're not a
victim I'm not saying she hasn't been a
victim in the past but right here he is
the victim you're making him out to be a
predator you're [__] putting the
camera at him without his [__]
consent you're calling them names this
is horrendous Behavior here and if a man
did this to a woman the [__] world
would end [__] sick of it
this is absolutely nuts right because
like when I remember like being her age
going to the gym for the first time just
like her didn't have a clue was weaker's
piss and I've got help from other older
trainers in it I didn't video them and
call them Predators I know it's
different for a woman and I don't know
her previous experiences but this
version of reality she is painting is
complete and a Fabrication in our head
adjusting my shots because I think I'm
the problem and bearing myself because
of the deep rooted misogyny I was
brought up with imagine having to adjust
your shorts and thinking that
[__] me honestly [__] today's generation
you lot are a bunch of whiny [__] I'm
sorry like I'm sick of yours I'm not
part of me working out by myself looks
like
I'm done you don't look like a damsel in
distress you just look like a gym guy
who doesn't know what they're doing
I'm safe
whatsoever this is why I hate the
internet if you happen to know this girl
you think about Daytona think twice
she's toxic I'm telling you now people
who've actually been through this stuff
don't usually [__] behave like this
kind of [__] it's such a misogynistic
World she's being brought up in and it's
so hard well loved get a [__] grip
will you some of you might see in that
this blew up on Twitter and then blew up
in her face because the world kind of
looked at her and realized what are you
talking about but there were some
sympathizers let's take Kevin for
example who said one of the worst
feelings I can only imagine I mean not
really right now you've got cancer is
bad you know find out a relative died
that's bad this ain't even top 20.
another comment here from a gym goer who
said it's normal for people to look at
lifting in a gym out of curiosity safety
this guy posted a video where he was
doing a lift to someone who he didn't
know a woman was watching him he isn't
freaking out about it he's not talking
about don't objectify me oh God like
it's not a problem
honestly this is insane man this is the
problem with the Internet is people have
got too much [__] time on their hands
to try and think of how to get viral
we're just just you know everyone to go
to war let's have a clear out this is a
good tweet as a deaf girl I study body
language a lot he was glancing over but
uncomfortably it does appear that she
was struggling and he was trying to be
the decent person to offer help girls
like this really ruin it for the rest of
us and not only do they ruin it for the
rest of of women out there who not men
now feel [__] we're terrified you
know we're [__] terrified of this
sort of [__] but equally they really
ruin it for real victims who are the
ones who need this support and
understanding in these situations and
videos like this make people skeptical
you know why are you doing this why are
you trying to record this why you're
trying to generate interest in yourself
you're trying to make yourself a little
Tick Tock star aren't you it trivializes
a real thing now I understand that this
really does happen absolutely it does
happen and Men you know a lot of them
are going into the gym because they want
to get laid that's a motivating factor
why men try in because they want to look
back out of attract women they're going
to gyms they see an attractive woman you
know you all of a sudden
you're not thinking straight for a split
second day and I understand women are
wearing very tight clothings in gyms and
as men we notice things this is biology
I'm not asking for you to give an
opinion on whether or not this happens
it's a fact in order for us to keep
making babies men off to find women
attractive that's a part of life ladies
and gentlemen sorry to drop that on you
but equally that's when you've got to do
the right thing and you know you notice
it as we all do women notice men I'm
sure it happens as well and then you get
back to doing what you're doing unless
there's some form of mutual situation
where both people are you know
interested in each other you see this is
an example of when this stuff actually
does happen you know when people really
are out of order a man was caught
masturbating near a woman doing squats
in South Africa I mean what the [__] bro
in the footage the man can be seen on an
exercise mat a few yards away from the
woman doing weighted squats while he
uses his phone with his right hand and
the other appears to be vigorously
moving yeah you get the idea we don't
need to watch it look at least someone
else caught him I mean literally he's
hardly hiding in there's [__] people
all over Jesus Christ what a Nutter and
that woman truly is a victim of that and
it I mean he deserves to be locked up
let's be real I mean if you're willing
to do that what other crazy [__] are you
doing so I think that clears up a few
things for the day are there some
horrible pervy guys and gyms all over
the world yes there are they're they're
everywhere actually
um not just in gyms however make sure
you know someone's actually a pervert
before filming them calling them names
uploading it to the internet and
insinuating that they are a pervert with
zero evidence to suggest that and that's
all I've got to say today don't forget
to hit that like button stay subscribed
to the true Geordie YouTube channel and
I'll catchers on the next one